welcome to Bel Air well
[Music]
how you been bro it's been a minute you
know thriving
you gonna ask me how I've been there no
you're gonna tell me why are you wearing
my clothes oh [ __ ] uh yeah Hillary sent
me up something about a failed growth
spurt
yeah I know it's cool
look it's just Dad believes that the
details make the math so if you're gonna
wear my 500 cufflinks
let's at least make sure
I've got to put your arm upright
appreciate that because hey no problem
I'm probably helping you out a lot
what do you mean by that oh you know
helping you fit in at school showing you
around
mom and dad said that you were out here
for a better education
yeah I mean we still trying to figure
out his little Arrangement type drawing
so yeah yeah
I hope one day we can talk about why
you're really here
I gotta go welcome to Bel Air well
yo so let me get this straight man you
really don't have a problem with a white
boy saying
right in front of your face it's just a
word dude chill out fine chilling out
your boy Chad was Wilding first of all
his name is Connor Connor Chad Brad
whatever the [ __ ] his Wonder Bread ass
name is he ain't with the culture
Carlton
and clearly you ain't neither
you're really flipping out over a word
that black rapper saw the millions of
white people like Connor every day and
you expect him to not say the words that
they're listening to
Carlton man you a clown yo straight off
go kiss my rich black ass boy you can
forget about coming to Connor's party
tonight [ __ ] that party hey
what the hell is going on here
we're good mom
just having a spirited debate right well
yeah
spirited
[Music]
foreign
to make me jealous
[Music]
foreign
you're okay
relax Lis he's okay all right he's just
doing this for attention
go chill out bro
[Music]
look we can just skip to the part where
you apologize and say sorry for what you
lay hands on me first where I come from
that's a green light to ground up
you know it's funny how the n-word
magically appears whenever you talk
about getting violent with a black
person and yet you think you're better
than Conor
let's see how far your ghetto code gets
you at my school
if you're gonna be able to get there
that is
change we shouldn't just be
oh [ __ ]
uh you know what Jerry it's fine don't
even worry about him
he's with me
maybe you can uh help us decide on a new
initiative to support
yeah come on over
well
this is the junior class everyone this
is my cousin will
it's his first day of Valor Academy
clearly he's gotten a little lost this
morning but uh give it time and I'm sure
he'll catch on and find this place let's
give
so will
can you tell us about the public school
you attended in Philadelphia
yeah I went to West Philly High School
how many AP classes did they offer
a few I think yeah I don't know what
about a study abroad program or a
student wellness center
see
this is why I think we need a change
you know instead of supporting some
Wildlife initiative halfway across the
world why don't we sponsor a struggling
Public School
right here in the LA area
because not all of those kids are going
to be as lucky as we'll here to transfer
to a school like ourselves well thank
you so much for your help today will
you can go
and again
welcome to Bel Air Academy
come on let's give him another hand
[Music]
another one
your boy's on fire you're slandering
dad's opponents and equating blue lives
matter with racism and I don't always
agree with them but you can't just call
all conservatives racists
um I can and it's working so why are you
bitching because you trample every rule
that you don't like but somehow you end
up the winner and you're completely
ignorant of everything outside your
beloved no I'm not [ __ ] ignorant
and trust me the next oh you're gonna
beat my ass cause that's how they do it
in Philly yo give it a goddamn rest all
right every hood is the same
I
and that's the reason why I can walk
around here and get all these signatures
and you walking around here with nothing
you know I'll give you something well
you're a much better [ __ ] artist
than I ever will be really and you can
talk you talk and do your thing you
might have everyone else fooled but not
me
did you really come out here for better
education will your friend Trey getting
shot was that just some random
coincidence or is there more to the
story
yeah
that's what I thought
you see I knew you were full of [ __ ]
from the moment you walked through our
door
man [ __ ] you
I'm out
yo Carlton you remember my boy Trey he
just came in from Philly yo what a
little see I didn't see since I was like
eight so
welcome to Bel Air Trey have fun
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]